[音楽]
こんにちは
松編みさあ高等部3年の脚戦車ですよろしくお願いします
私は人生におけるべくる公園の時間を海外で過ごしてきました
今回はスレチは私はこの海外生活を子どもの視点から何が米たのかを振り返りながらお
抹茶と思います
最初に私はアメリカの方に行きました
その時私は2歳が入ったんですが
あんまり強化内で今回つ課税しておきます
それで次に私はシンガポールできました
ここには発生感を進めたんですよ
まあもう
一番滞在期間が長いので第五の小京都行ってるよと私はこの国が大好きです
皆さん
この国といえば何を思い浮かべますでしょうか
例えば位
皆さん拍手屋上に触れがですマリーが day 3です
世界三大がっかり名所の一つでしたいているマーライオン
そしてドリアンドームの減少で知られているストレイドシアターといろいろありますよ
こんないろいろなの中で私が一番
すごい印象に残ったほうがいいです
審理したんですけ
新兵衛氏はタミール語中国語
マレーを英語が混ざっておりまして独特な名前がある
英語なんですけど
例えば一つ例を挙げますと
キャン遊戯ビアでしたうんん
安くしてくる
これがシングリッシュなるぞなんとちーパーラー
ここにターン肥爪しまうんですね
必要最低限の言語観光声だけ
もう
ぴシンガポール店通じてそうなんです
それでまあいろんなことがありながらん
まあいい思い出があったと思う
次屋小学校を卒業して中学生の私は言う
ドバイに行くんですね
泊まり入れやまあなんかすごい豪華検眼なイメージがあると思いました
その通りなんですね
世界一変えたブルーじゃないかという
屋内スキー場屋内スキー場がありました
まだ砂漠の中に増のホテルが安泰と思う
すごいユダが区にあるつん
ノブな人ですなかった方がいい
夏はこう10度いくんですね暑いってが痛いんですねこれが
なんか私は帰れませんでした
でこの国では介在は
のイスラム教に対する理解もた作るに深めておりました
例えばですよね一つ話を開けると私の友達
結びがあるんですけども
僕は学校にいるんですねでお弁当時間にお惣菜交換しようとか言って応援と狡猾んです
けどその時私間違って豚肉を
のムースでの政府をあげてしまいました
娘のちゃぶ台子が食べないんですねお店に来たちゃう
ドン引きされましたよ
なんで渡すんだん
そんなこんなでいろいろありましたけど
まあなんかここまで話聞いてると今後
こいつた地盤待ちしてなきゃいかんだよ
間に生還のみたいな話になるんですけど
次のだしプロ声に映るんですけど
ここへ電話生活はまた人は10着一人ですね
ちょっと想像もつかないような経験をした子で
それはその先ず一つで空港から a マヨ解密ではまず思いました
存在が充填してまして車が止まっていたんですね
それでまあ中遅いなーて思ってたんですよ
そしたらまあも外から
花束を持った女バー
窓をノックしてきたんですね
おでん私は驚きました
法則同0なんで女はかかってるんだろ
それは産後5その指令に切りからん
それは女の子はあなたバグってその日を言ってるんだよって言ってました
その時に私は
今までこんなんかあそういったゾンビでなんか何もし滞納しても特産しても分かって
一方で
そんなのかその日を生きるためだけに一生懸命働いて
そういうのを見て話さ
というか同じ人間なのに生まれた場所が違うだけ
今環境が変わってくれること
ただショックを覚えました私は
またトルコでは貧困だけではなくて
でも返してたんですね
これで模写しないけれども
2のそのでもはプラカードを持ってその講義室で更新する
そういったでもあるんですけども
努力も電話
きちゃいました
警察が縫製銃や催涙ガスそれが使わなきゃいけないほど暴走か者でもあったんですね
その時私の挽き白レが被害なりまして
さゆりが数遅れましてそれで一行
呼吸困難に陥りました
そんなの未定
ました自分も被害に遭う者良い
た強風さ
中学3ゲーセン行った私は
先生受験鮭があったんだよ
日本に戻りました
この日本にもって
なんか努力の情勢弾もかかることはないのかと思っ
ですけどそんなことなかったんです
私は今でもそのとおりこの友だちを選んだことを言うんですよ
その時に決まっては第2弾があってくるなぁ
登録のことなんですね
トルコへ食えた ok とかそれこの情報規制は唯一ゆがみれない体するか使えないと
かそんな話が毎回があってください
一度関わったらもう一キャンプから日犬です
そんな話を聞いてうちに私は
このは現地から一歩離れいうことやって
この状況客観視レバーになりました
その中で気づいたことはい
世界中にも寺を切ってローってますよ
命が失われてるって点では同じなのに
先進国と途上国はテロどちらん報道のされ方が違うことなんですよね
例えば記憶に新しい巴里の灯だますよ
ご視聴者数が130人以上寝てるんですけど
1本や取るかよ寺北店ですね
で死亡者数がいい
652ズレてんですご存知の方ってのはどれ今ているようなことをご存じな方が多く
ないと思うんですけども
それをなぜならん
ゼットン散歩上木ニュースがネットの隅っこの方に乗るだけで大々的にはその報道され
ないからなんですね
コーンコーラーかで会ってるぞ
報道されなかった人々のには者掲載じゃないこと
私はこのままに怒りを覚えます
そしてネットニュースさ隅っこにあるニュースは
ん
1面を飾る事件よりも実は被害者を受けているものもあります
今回のステージを聞いたからで少しでもその登場他ニュースに関心を持ったからだ
まず盗賊の問題をしてくださいその第一歩として
空いた時間に良いのでその
ヘッド3個なるニュースを読んでいただければ私はうれしいです
ご清聴痛いました
[拍手]